[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich danke für ihre bisherige
leistungsbereitschaft bedanken dass sie
die ausbildung die auch in diesen
kritischen bei der bundeswehr angetreten
haben bleiben sie unterhalten sie sich
ihre leistungsbereitschaft ich kann
ihnen versichern den sie mit arbeiten in
ihren bereichen positiv dass gerade
soldat und das wechselt oder das
funktions und in verschiedensten
funktionen werden die sechs leute sehr
schnell vergeben sodass und 20 sowie so
bleiben
ich wünsche ihnen ihre kameraden für die
kommenden monate bei ihrer zeit die
österreichischen bundesheer viel mut und
ausdauer bei dieser gelebten mutigen
kameradschaft
gerade zu zeiten nur so viele
herausforderungen gibt brauchen sie das
brauchen wir das gemeinsam alle ich
wünsche ihnen daher gute vertrauens
beziehungen die dazu führen dass man
sich gegenseitig unterstützt und dass
man weiß dass man sich in
extremsituationen danach auf die
kameraden verlassen kann
gott segne sie und bewahre sie in ihrem
dienst am bürger das geld angesprochen
phase eines durch die gerade geredet
wird und dass auch sie so in nächster
zukunft hinzukommen und werden wird sie
werden beitragen
für den schutz österreichs und der
deutschen bevölkerung sie werden damit
in die fußstapfen ihrer kameraden
treffen
wird die vorigen wm aufgaben und
herausforderungen wünsche ich ihnen als
bei der deko land von dem alles
erdenklich gute seite sie einsatz sowohl
die bundeshauptstadt und sowohl auf
europäischer seite
ich gelobe republik und gold besitzen
[Applaus]
nicht gelungen
das ist selbst und den gesetzmäßigen
können ohne und die hosen und zu leisten
[Applaus]
alle befehle meine vorgesetzten und sich
um zu gewinnen
auch gehörten sofort zu bieten